the swamp lands of
America a habitat with a forever
shifting
terrain this is the home of some of the
most
mysterious and monstrous creatures on
the
planet creatures who kill to
survive from
Dust Till da these animals rage
War there's no
escaping the
horrors of a night in the
swamps
There Are Places on the
planet where the boundaries between land
and water
blur these are the swamp lands of the
American
[Music]
South and and they span hundreds of
miles across an Ever Changing terrain of
shallow water channels muddy flats and
towering
Cyprus some of the most terrifying
creatures on the planet Thrive
here and many of these living nightmares
emerge in the
dark
but in a swamp death does not wait for
Darkness to
emerge The Killing Starts
Now with the sun low on the
horizon thousands of swamp birds
returned to roost in nests they built up
to 9 ft above the
[Music]
[Applause]
water from these perches they keep a
close watch on the water
below Waters patrolled constantly by
predators
[Music]
one of their greatest threats is a
massive
Hunter who can grow to be nearly 15 ft
long and weigh up to 1,000
lb this is the American
[Music]
alligator
and he keeps most of his size
hidden beneath the
[Music]
surface
you
the alligator is
fast but not fast
[Music]
enough but the real reason he's come
here is for something a little more
Sinister it's breeding
season and this Rookery is full of
vulnerable flightless chicks
inevitably some of the young fall from
the safety of their
nests and unable to swim or fly there's
little
hope because it's only a matter of time
before an alligator spots
them
[Music]
this Sunset kill begins another
countdown to
Dawn
the swamp lands radically transform in
the dark but there's more to this world
than meets the
eye especially beneath the surface of
the
water down here one of the swamp's
deadliest Predators begins his hunt with
the rising of the
[Music]
Moon
this is an alligator snapping
[Music]
turtle this bottom dweller rarely leaves
the
water and with nostrils located on the
tip of his snout taking a breath of
fresh air is as simple as briefly
piercing the
surface His Kind can weigh nearly 300
lb and they bulk up by feeding on just
about anything that swims too close to
their powerful hooked
Jaws he barely moves when he
hunts except to wiggle his
tongue that mimics a drowning
worm the inside of his mouth is
camouflaged making his tongue stand out
to unsuspecting
prey
[Music]
like any patient
fisherman he lets the bait do the
work attracting his
prey before going for the
catch
his Target gets
away but he's got all
night and there are plenty of fish in
the
swamp
quick as the turtle might be so far
tonight his prey is a little
faster but the fish's explosive getaway
lands it in
trouble it's accidentally beached itself
onto the land of the
[Music]
dead as seasonal changes cause the water
levels to recede many fish get stranded
on
Shore and this attracts corpse eaters
from all over the
swamp
there is no escaping death in this
American
swamp and for fish beached on
Shore there's no
hope especially with Predators nearby
who hunger for the dying and the
[Music]
dead this is a cartton mouth a venomous
snake who hunts both on land and in the
[Music]
water G can't resist an easy
target and puts The Beached fish out of
its misery by swallowing it
whole
cotton Moes like other pit vipers have
special organs that give them thermal
imaging of their
environment and your six sense detects
something strange approaching
an armored eight-legged
scavenger who can regenerate lost
limbs and seiz with excellent vision
from protruding eyes on the ends of
stocks this is a
crawfish but it's just
one in a horde of many
and they emerge in the
Moonlight migrating over land in search
of new feeding
grounds equipped with sharp pincers in a
Tough kitan
Armor they swarm like a living flood
across the muddy
flats and they'll consume just about
anything in their
[Applause]
path even a venomous snake like the
cotton mouth flees from this deadly
[Music]
[Applause]
kind The Horde lets her
go because they can't resist the sweet
smell of Rotting
[Music]
Flesh the Crustaceans prefer to to eat
in water so they drag their catch below
where they can take it apart Peace by
beast but the Crawfish aren't the only
swarming scavengers in this strange
Underwater
World the swamp teams with another group
of tiny crustations
and they haunt the shallows like
Phantoms these are ghost
shrimp and like
crawfish they emerge at night to
feed swimming near each other in a
nocturnal underwater balance
[Music]
away their transparent bodies provide
nearly perfect
[Music]
camouflage so they can hide from the
bigger Predators who stalk the swamp
bottom
attracted by the ghost shrimp's activity
a seny predator emerges from
[Music]
hiding but this long slender swamp
dweller isn't a
snake this is a
siren an aquatic Salam maner who enjoys
a good shrimp
cocktail but he has to be
careful because in the water there's
always a bigger Predator
[Music]
nearby a hungry mud snake spots the
siren
but the Slender amphibian is quick and
gets
away the mud snake returns to the
hunt but in the leaf litter sometimes
it's best to stay
still and let your prey come to
you this alien like Hunter mimics a
leaf only breaking the surface of the
water to
breathe through his
[Music]
butt he's a giant water
bug and he's one of the most patient
hunters in the
swamp for
him timing is
everything
his Target
escapes but there are others of his kind
waiting nearby like
[Music]
landmines these small fish spend the
night navigating a
gauntlet of camouflaged
killers
[Music]
and it's only a matter of
time before one ins snares its
prey the giant waterbug grips his catch
subduing it with his venomous
beak
stragglers still scaring for scraps on
land are
vulnerable especially when hungry
scavengers stalk the
[Applause]
shoreline
like a furry
Bandit who no stranger to
humans a
raccoon but this swamp dweller isn't
spoiled like his Urban relatives with
access to human
waste if this country boy wants to eat
he has to work for
it and that means dipping his
hands into Dangerous
Waters raccoons have the most highly
developed sense of touch and dexterity
of all
convor but filling through the Merc is
extremely
risky especially with Hunters lurking
just beneath the
surface a raccoon reaches into a deadly
abyss of an American
swamp a place home to unimaginable
dangers the raccoon's frantic search for
food sends vibrations and noise Rippling
through the
water alerting aquatic Predators hunting
[Music]
nearby
the alligator snapping turtles strike on
the catfish reminds the raccoon of the
swamp's
dangers the turtle grips the fish with
his long claws while hammering away at
it with his hooked
beak other Hunters watch from a distance
as the turtle butchers his
catch
small aquatic scavengers
approach while the turtle shreds the
catfish into
pieces he's a Messy
eater and the Crawfish get their fair
share of
scraps but while they feed in the water
on
land someone searches for a
[Music]
drink this is the Pome
a nocturnal
marsupio with an omnivorous
diet one that include
snakes the par immune to snake venom and
the cotton mouth recognizes the threat
he
poses so he takes up a defensive
position causing his Hunter to hesitate
and in the swamp a moment's hesitation
can lead to
disaster
[Music]
faced with a creature powerful enough to
bring down the forest the posum and
cotton mouth
Retreat allowing the furry Lumberjack to
continue his work in
peace this is the
beaver one one of the only animals on
the planet who
re-engineers the environment to suit
their
needs with his powerful bite he cuts
down trees and branches that he uses to
build his Fortress like
Lodge but what's a castle without a
moat the beaver also constructs dams
that flood the area around his
[Music]
home providing him with protection from
Outsiders but he has to leave sometimes
to forage for
food and in the swamp there's always
someone waiting in the
water this alligator devoured a baby
bird Just Before
Sunset
but that's not nearly enough meat to
satisfy his
hunger he's ready for the main
course and few things are
better then a plump
beaver a mouth of sharp
teeth a way to Beav her in the dark
Waters of an American
swamp the beaver makes it back to the
safety of his lodge just in
time leaving the alligator out in the
cold but while he goes
hungry on Shore a young Hunter HS her
killing
craft she's a
bobcat a specialist in population
control
who takes her job very
seriously experience comes with
age and she's just learning the
ropes but her instincts tell her to move
quietly as she tracks an unforgettable
scent belonging to a risky
Target it's less than half her size but
it trudges confidently through the
brush showing no fear of this dark and
deadly
swamp a
stunk the Bobcat's curious but
cautious because his bold stripes are a
warning to others to keep their
distance or risk the wrath of his
powerful
defense a chemical cocktail from the
glands on its
rear which can cause
nausea intense pain or even
blindness and makes you stink for
weeks
but this is a lesson the young buob gats
yet to
learn
spotting the Bobcat just in time
Nature's stink bomb delivers a potent
dose of his smelly
spray the Bobcat nurses her nose and her
Pride as the skunk
escapes from the murky Waters to the
muddy Flats the swamp's everchanging
landscape can be a hunter's worst
enemy only a few Unique Individuals are
Adept at navigating through all these
different
terrains and one of them is the second
longest snake in North
America this is a black rat
snake and His Kind can grow to be up to
8 ft
long
[Music]
he Maneuvers just as easily through the
water as he does over
land but right now he's locked onto
something that's high up in the
air
[Music]
using specially angled
scales his body grips to tree
bark allowing him to defy
gravity as he slithers up the
trunk
like a thief in a night he approaches
the
home of a sleeping
[Music]
victim the swamp's bidnight Strangler
enters the home of a sleeping
squirrel he wraps around his victim
before they can wait
up and strangles them to
death it's over in a few
moments and a snake DS on his
[Music]
prey
while a killing unfolds in the upper
floors of the
[Music]
tree down below a strange neighbor of
the
squirrels has yet to emerge from his
dark
dwelling
this odd mammal wears armor made of
plates of dermal
bone and it's strong enough to protect
him from all but the deadliest
bites this is a nine banded
armadillo and he comes out at night to
search for grubs in a swamp land soft
wet
soil with extremely poor vision he
relies on his powerful sense of
smell and he's able to sniff out prey
buried over a half a foot
underground but with his head dug in the
sand his main sense is occupied
and he's oblivious to approaching
danger the
bobg still hungry and on the
hunt She's Not Afraid of taking on an
opponent with a strong defensive
game
but with the stench of skunk spray
clinging to her
fur a stealthy approach goes out the
window but the armadillo has an Escape
Plan
he can
swim able to hold his breath for up to 6
minutes the agile swimmer escapes the
Bobcat but in the water he captures
someone else's
[Music]
attention
in the murky depths of the swamp even
the most experienced Hunters make
mistakes and the alligator catches
nothing but a mouthful of
branches allowing the armadillo to get
[Music]
away but while he's been running for his
life one of his fellow mammals exits the
water to give himself some
[Music]
TLC this giant rodent is a
nutria and he's fastidious about his
personal
hygiene the armadillo leaves his
Carefree neighbor to go about his Beauty
regiment in
peace glands near his mouth produce oils
that he rubs all over his
body this special lotion helps
waterproof his
fur
making navigating the water a little
[Music]
easier with his huge yellow teeth he
spends most of his time devouring
Wetland
plants
he and his kin are so hungry they can do
serious damage to a swamp habitat by
[Music]
overfeeding but in the
water he's vulnerable to a
patroller who balances the scales for
this
ecosystem
the gator locks the mutria in his
sights and he doesn't plan on missing
again a nutrio Gorges on
Plants unaware he has a
stalker
Nea are an invasive species who have
disrupted the swamp ecosystem since
their introduction in the late 19th
century
the Gators here play a huge role in
controlling their
population for the good of
[Music]
all with an hour left to Dawn an eerie
calm settles over the
wetlands but not everyone's ready to
call it the
n
a red fox emerges from the
Shadows he prows the wet lands like a
[Music]
phantom and few see him coming until
it's too
[Music]
late but right now his eyes and ears
lock onto a strange corner of the
[Music]
[Applause]
swamp
[Music]
a dwelling inhabited by bizarre fleshy
beings who walk on two
[Music]
[Applause]
legs the fox has come to know this place
as a sord of easy
food but his distant cousin has allied
with these house
dwellers and sounds the
alarm so he has to choose his approach
[Music]
carefully
w
[Music]
with the coast
clear the fox comes out of hiding and
goes after his
Target a yummy bowl of d dog
food the night nears its
end and many have fallen to the violence
and Decay that are a part of life in the
swamp Hunters bearing the scars of their
nocturnal fight
look for a safe place to
heal and pray return to their dwellings
to
rest as the Sun finally breaks over the
horizon but this reprieve from the dark
horrors of the swamp is always an
illusion because this is a place that's
equal parts beautiful
F and
[Music]
deadly